kanye west comes out and says i want to
run for office
and by the way pull up the tweet when he
put this out there that he's running for
office what was crazy about the fact
when he put it up that he's running for
office
guess who all of a sudden tweets in the
dialogue
the one and only elon musk elon musk
weighs in on it and
and here's what kanye says we must now
realize the promise of america by
trusting god
unifying our vision and building our
future
i am running for president of the united
states
2020 vision and elon musk
says somewhere if you can find it he
says right there
you have my full support
you have my full support so point two
percent to two percent is this real or
is just
just a marketing gimmick well let me
just quickly point out two things or one
thing that elon musk and kanye both have
in common
they're both african-americans if you
think about that is a good point because
he's from south africa from south africa
i see all of these people that are like
uh
west musk 2020 and i'm like he can't
even be vice president
he was born in south africa but they got
to change the law for a guy like that to
be able to run by yeah yeah
you got to change the law for a guy like
to be able to run let me uh let me let
me
intersect the first uh segment with the
kanye section tell us what was kanye's
first
big album well it was called the college
dropout that's where he came on the
scene so
there it is you don't need college next
thing you know you might become the
president of the united states right
listen this gives one of these let me
tell probably there we go that's a proud
moment
he was the college it was the college
dropout now he's running for president
there's hope for everyone out there
so what do you think what do you think
about this do you but on a serious note
on a free assume camera's not there
we're just talking is it real or is it
purely marketing okay so
so i number one point of fact
kanye west has an album coming out in
2020. so you do the math is he
actually really going to be running for
president he is dropping an album he is
a marketing genius
clearly okay and i think there's a part
of it that somehow this is going to end
up helping trump
in the end right he went into trump's uh
he's going to josh's boy
he went to the trump's office what a
year ago i love this man he went on a
rant
he might be crazier than trump and i'll
take away might
and say he's probably crazier than trump
but he's a marketing genius
he's got his girl kim who i happen to
know back in the day
and she's supporting him she's got her
full support and uh
so it's not real you're saying it's not
real it's fake he doesn't stand a single
chance
correct but by the way let me ask you
let me go level i'm going to come to you
next
do you think he doesn't stand a single
chance on this one or we will never see
kanye as president
i'm going to go out on a limb and say
kanye west will never
be president of the united states now
maybe use on a sound bite in the future
for the rest of your life your kids are
going to watch you say something like
that if he happens to be
if kanye west becomes president united
states i will
kiss josh's toes his feet his maga
loving feet
and uh so netting zero chance no chance
zero chance now let me ask you a
different question here's a different
question for you no chance
in 26 2015 when trump walked down the
escalator
with his wife and he said he's running
for office what did you say was the
chance of him winning that day
let's back up a second as much as i'm
not a trump fan i will say
successful businessman you know
built a lot of businesses so what did
you say when he said that though in that
moment what did you say in 2015. he and
he made his comment
we have a lot of people that are coming
from the west mexicans rapists and
and drug drug dealers and all that can
you tell me exactly what he said some i
guess
are good people okay you know pretty
does intro to racism didn't you say he
stood a chance in that moment
well you got to understand trump ran for
president yesterday
i will i know i did i never gave trump a
zero percentage okay so you never i was
never going to go away
that's running for president okay so so
you said he stands a chance yes
so he stood a bigger chance of becoming
the president and then kanye is what you
say wouldn't you agree that
i'm asking you okay what do you think
ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the greatest move by
president trump
since i don't know last election let me
tell you exactly what's going on here
trump is putting money in kanye's
coffers
because he knows without a shadow of a
doubt that kanye west
is joe biden's worst nightmare besides
joe biden
okay let me tell you exactly what's
happening here kanye is gonna be able to
split a bunch of the millennial
and black vote that would normally go to
joe biden one of the greatest things
that we've learned from our good friend
roger stone who
we have an interview you've never
checked it out go check it out on
valuetainment
roger stone one of the greatest
political strategists of our time
he always says this if you know it's
going to be a close election
the greatest thing that you could do is
go get somebody that's
gonna split the vote put money in their
coffers and let them fight it out
this is what trump's doing we know that
uh
that our good friend kanye is a maga
supporter
we also know that he has a lot of uh
friends
on the left we know that he has a lot of
uh sway
especially with the black community the
hip hop community not as much as you
would think
bro i'm telling you not as much as you
would think gosh
okay elaborate what do you mean he
doesn't have as much there's actually
been polls of
support and let's see let me find some
stats there's actually been some polls
of
what african-americans think of kanye
it's not as high as you would think
you know who does who the blacks
community does support way more than
kanye what's that kanye's mentor one
one man named jay-z who's married to
beyonce big fans of obama yeah big fans
of obama
came out in full support of hillary
clinton last time as you can recall
backfired but i wouldn't i wouldn't go
that far let me ask you a good question
can i walk into a trap
let me walk into another question adam
are you telling me you won't vote for
kanye
zero you know what this means ladies and
gentlemen a black man is running for
president
and adam is still going to vote for the
old white guy which means
you my friend are a racist do black
lives not matter to you adam black lives
do you not care about a black man
running for president
are you telling me right now they will
do this absolute marketing
genius he's scamming the people to even
look look at us talking about it okay
look at a question
question yeah go ahead you have the
three choices of candidates
biden trump kanye top three orders who
would you just said it right there who
would you who'd you vote
you just said it what would you say
you'd vote biden first yes who's next
for you
trump then by oh yeah so connie's last
no fair enough
he's being reasonable this has nothing
to do with black white orange
well certainly somebody say it's racist
a little bit because i'm just saying
some people might say so
any black guy that runs and i'm like oh
i'm not into it no no i'm not saying i'm
saying i never said i said it i said
some may call you that because you're
living in america and i voted for obama
twice proudly
my question to you is this that okay
i just need some water as one of our
incredible viewers just pointed out yes
kim kardashian getting her law degree
yeah possible that she runs in eight to
16 years
you know what this is so so let me see
let me say this let me say this
part you know what let me say this part
do you know what roger stone said is the
hardest i said is the hardest thing to
do to become a candidate
you know what's the hardest thing he
said being known being known
is the number one factor of being a
president for sure
being known